und jetzt das heute journal
mit kaiser richter und christian sievers
und nahm den allen es gibt heute bilder
zu sehen bei denen wir uns die augen
reiben wenn sich machtverhältnisse
verschieben wenn die geopolitische lage
ins rutschen gerät dann lässt sich das
selten so klar und deutlich zeigen wie
hier ein kleiner videoclip nur auf einer
landstraße im norden von syrien rechts
rücken die truppen des diktators assad
vor links auf der gegenfahrbahn zieht
sich die mächtige us armee zurück donald
trump will es so und er merkt
gleichzeitig was er damit anrichtet eine
türkische militär offensive war die
folge tote verletzte 160.000 menschen
auf der flucht
womöglich entscheidender für den
us-präsidenten ist die massive kritik zu
hause in amerika diplomatisches versagen
militärische erniedrigung dass es noch
eine der zurückhaltenden reaktionen
jedenfalls fordert der mann der die
entwicklung der letzten tage überhaupt
erst möglich gemacht hat jetzt einen
stopp der türkischen offensive und
kündigt wirtschaftssanktionen an
taktik oder chaos im weissen haus
washington el mati wissen
türkische soldaten finden leere räume in
einem gefängnis für es terroristen
solche bilder sind der albtraum für alle
kritiker des amerikanischen truppen
rückzugs tausende sollen entkommen sein
und die hauptnachrichten in den usa
zeigen anderes kämpfer in vorfreude auf
die chance unterzutauchen
jeder hier hat ein gutes gefühl dass
bald irgendjemand anders hier zuständig
ist
die supermacht staut sich nach hause das
syrische regime übernimmt und mit ihm
als wichtigste sponsoren russland und
iran
im ehemaligen hochburgen des e es werden
menschen verletzt und getötet und die
die amerika im kampf gegen die s und
assad-regime geholfen haben die kurden
ernten ganz offenbar den spott des
amerikanischen präsidenten
wer immer syrien helfen will die kurden
zu schützen sehr gern russland china
oder napoleon bonaparte ganz legal ist
es dem weißen haus doch nicht denn
vizepräsident pence soll übermorgen
mit präsident erdogan in der türkei
verhandeln sanktionen unter anderem
gegen drei türkische minister sind
angekündigt weil erdogan angeblich zu
weit gehen die vereinigten staaten haben
der türkei kein grünes licht gegeben in
syrien einzumarschieren
der präsident hat das gegenüber
präsident erdogan jetzt auch noch mal
klar nur wie ernst meint es trump der
heute das eishockey meister team empfing
er will nun das eis brechen zwischen den
konfliktparteien vermitteln und dann den
geplant und trotz allem noch nicht
abgesagt mitte november rezept erdogan
hier im weißen haus begrüßen
wir fordern einen waffenstillstand haben
die schärfsten sanktionen verhängt und
haben noch mehr wenn sie nicht will
trumps parteifreunde im kongress machen
druck sehen im truppenabzug selbst das
falsche signal an erdogan
sie fordern eine massive eskalation der
sanktion wir werden ein klares signal an
die türkei erdogan und die welt senden
wir werden seine wirtschaft brechen bis
er das blutvergießen stoppen
aber sanktionen wirken erst in wochen so
dass erdogan some er am boden blutig
fakten schaffen kann mit geopolitischen
folgen denn die syrische armee strömten
längst verlorene gebiete zurück ein sieg
für das assad-regime für russland und
vor allem für iran so kritiker es gibt
ein tieferes problem hier das gibt iran
freiraum in syrien iran will einen
landweg zur mittelmeerküste und das ist
eine gefahr für israel militärisch
hätten die usa das verhindern können für
viele fühlte sich deshalb an wie eine
niederlage im kampf gegen den us und
andere böse kräfte
es ist wie im strategiespiel ein
machtvakuum bleibt nicht lange eines was
der eine aufgibt wird an anderer füllen
im grunde ganz einfach nur dass man nie
vergessen darf was da passiert vor
unseren augen in den kurdengebieten
syriens ist kein spiel
da bezahlen unschuldige menschen mit
ihrem leben der führende player in
syrien heißt längst russland und weil
russische truppen von amerikanischen
gerade quasi ganze städte übernehmen
dass der einfluss des kreml noch einmal
enorm gewachsen für wladimir putin ist
der weg frei in der region
und er hat einen plan bernhard lichter
berichtet der kreml her auf staatsbesuch
syriens nachbarn stehen auf dem programm
erstmals seit zwölf jahren wieder nach
saudi arabien die vereinigten emirate in
abu dhabi einen putin der neben
wirtschaftlichen und kulturellen themen
vor allem geostrategischer ambitionen
erkennen lässt
wir koordinieren sehr intensiv regionale
und internationale probleme die eng
verbunden sind mit der lage in syrien
libyen dem jemen und der gesamtsituation
in der golfregion schiedsrichter will
putin sein
moskaus einfluss in diesem teil der welt
unumkehrbar machen 2011 sprang russland
dem bedrängten syrischen machthaber
assad politisch bei vor vier jahren
folgte das militärische engagement nun
also die neue landkarte nahost
gezeichnet mit dem russischen stift
russlands grenzen enden nirgendwo
verkündet das transparente am eingang
der basis remis von der orthodoxen
kirche bis zur freizeiteinrichtungen ist
alles da sie sind gekommen um dauerhaft
zu bleiben
in der abgeschiedenheit der russischen
basis trafen sich auch vertreter der
kurden und der syrischen armee im
vorfeld der türkischen militäraktion
loteten die gegner von gestern ihre
künftigen gemeinsamkeiten aus ankara
kontrolliert mittlerweile etwa 1000
quadratkilometer syrischen territoriums
entlang seiner grad
operation friedens quelle nennt sich die
vorgebliche säuberung von
terrororganisationen die tatsächlich
aber eine vertreibung der ungeliebten
kunden darstellt der proteste aus moskau
ist verhalten
jeder der sich illegal auf dem
territorium eines anderen staates
aufhält in diesem fall der republik
syrien muss das gebiet verlassen das
gilt für alle start und wenn eine
künftige legitime syrische regierung die
anwesenheit unseres militärs nicht mehr
für nötig hält betrifft das
selbstverständlich auch russland noch
ist es nicht soweit
moskau macht sich unentbehrlich indem es
direkte konfrontationen zwischen
syrischem und türkischen militär
verhindert in der konsequenz bedeutet
dass freie hand für erdogan
die beiden herren brauchen einander
beseelt vom wunsch im nahen osten ein
großer player zu sein der türke der
russe als ordnungsmacht überall dort wo
die usa eine lücke hinterlassen haben
drei millionen dollar täglich kostet das
allein russland aus moskauer sicht eine
durchaus lohnende investition sichert
sie doch neben politischem einfluss auch
den zugriff auf energie und andere
ressourcen
so den mann im kreml und seine strategie
haben wir gerade gesehen
sigmar gabriel kümmert sich um enge
bande zwischen deutschland und den usa
er ist der vorsitzende des netzwerks
atlantik-brücke er ist natürlich auch
ein ehemaliger außenminister der
bundesrepublik deutschland genannt herr
gabriel ganz große cabrio sie machen das
beruflich die usa verstehen verstehen
sie noch welche strategie donald trump
da jetzt im moment fährt
ich musste ihnen widersprechen das ist
ein ehrenamt der vorsitz der
atlantik-brücke trotzdem geht es ja um
die frage verstehen wir das und man muss
einfach sehen dass die politik schon vor
trump begonnen hat aus meiner sicht aus
sicht der usa große fehler zu machen
damals europäer immer davor gewarnt zu
unterschätzen was die türkei tun wird
wenn die vereinigten staaten eine
teilorganisation der pkk das ja eine
organisation die auch in deutschland
verboten ist und die versucht ein teil
der türkei abzuspalten wenn die usa mit
dieser teilorganisation der pkk
zusammenarbeiten und die türken die
sorge haben dass einer nordgrenze
syriens ein pkk staat entsteht wir haben
immer davor gewarnt dass zu machen weil
egal wer in der türkei
die mehrheit hat wird versuchen das mit
allen mitteln notfalls eben leider auch
mit militärischen mitteln zu unterbinden
also ich glaube dass die fehler deutlich
vor der jetzigen politik gemacht und
sind aber was die usa jetzt tun ist
insofern besonders problematisch weil
ich vermute das haben sie vorhin auch
beschrieben der große gewinner jetzt
russland sein wird der große gewinner
ist russland iran auch vielleicht auch
recep tayyip erdogan am ende geben noch
mal ganz kurz auf die aktuelle situation
sie haben gesagt gerade das ist schon
viel länger ein problem eigentlich auch
schon unter der vorherigen
administration obama in den usa aber
donald trump hat ja quasi jetzt sowas
wie grünes licht gegeben durch seinen
truppenabzug für diese offensive der
türken wir haben jetzt eine region im
chaos wir es droht eine neue
flüchtlingskatastrophe und jetzt macht
traumpass ganz anderes er sagt nämlich
das muss alles sofort stoppen und droht
den türken wirtschaftssanktionen an was
was will er damit bezweckt mit welchen
eindruck würde damit hinterlassen in
ankara erstmal wieder eindruck in
amerika hinterlassen weil diese
entscheidung im groß
ein grünes licht zu geben für die
deutsche invasion in nordsyrien
natürlich in den vereinigten staaten
auch in seiner eigenen partei den
republikaner zu massiver kritik geführt
hat gibt massive kritik militär und der
kongress setzt gesetzgebungen in gang
die die türkische regierung mit
sanktionen belegen sollen und trump will
das abfedern und versucht innenpolitisch
die wogen zu glätten ich glaube darum
geht es ihm in erster linie der schaden
der in nordsyrien entstanden ist der
wird so schnell nicht gut zu machen sein
die gemeinsame position europa sieht im
moment so aus dass europa verurteilt
aufs schärfste
das sind worte die wir auch vom
deutschen außenminister vom aktuellen
deutschen außenminister hört was sollte
dann europa ton ihrer meinung nach jetzt
ganz aktuell und konkret na ja es wäre
schon gut gewesen wenn das waffenembargo
von ganz europa getragen worden wäre
dass das nicht der fall ist zeigt schon
die fragmentierte innerhalb der
europäischen union
ansonsten ist doch klar dass europa auch
seine eigenen interessen schützen will
in europa hat auf der einen seite kein
interesse und will alles dafür tun dass
die kriegerischen auseinandersetzungen
gestoppt werden weil das menschen
tragödien sind die da entstehen
auf der anderen seite haben wir
natürlich angst davor dass bei zu großem
innenpolitischen druck auf die türkei
das sagen alle abkommen die wir auch wir
mit der türkei haben und die uns
schützen vor noch grösseren flüchtlings
zuwanderung dass die gekündigt werden
europa ist in einer ganz schwierige lage
europa verlässt sich wenn es um seine
eigene sicherheit geht ja offensichtlich
immer noch um auf die usa auch in zeiten
von donald trump müsste europa müssten
deutschland frankreich zum beispiel der
ganz aktuellen situation und wie zu
entschärfen mich auch eigene truppen
schicken am ende das wäre ja der helle
wahnsinn in eine solche situation völlig
unvorbereitet militärisch einzugreifen
dafür dass einfach zu spät
wir wir haben uns von anfang an aus
diesem konflikt heraushalten wollen
in der hoffnung er berührt uns nicht wir
haben das alles anderen überlassen
und jetzt sozusagen im nachhinein solche
ideen zu entwickeln halte ich nicht für
besonders hilfreich ich glaube was wir
machen müssen es erstens in dieser
situation in der tat alle kanäle nutzen
und ich meine dass volkswagen eine große
investition gestoppt hat in der türkei
das setzt schon die türkei massiv unter
druck dass waffenhandel in dieser
situation geht überhaupt nicht
wir müssen natürlich auch darauf hoffen
dass das was russland und die usa da
jetzt machen dazu führt dass diese
konfrontation gestoppt wird für die
zukunft gebe ich ihnen recht europa wird
nicht anders können als selbst sich auch
in schwierigen situationen einzubringen
ich meine
zurzeit haben wir in libyen eine
situation dass ein mitgliedsstaat der eu
italien die regierung unterstützt ein
anderer mitgliedsstaat nämlich
frankreich den bürger kriegsgegner
general haft da das zwei europäische
mitgliedsstaaten in der gleichen region
unterstützen zwei bürgerkriegsparteien
das können wir uns einfach nicht mehr
erlauben in zukunft sie sagen also mehr
druck auf die türkei der türkische
präsident verbittet sich das und er
droht europa ganz offen manche sagen
auch er erpresst europa indem er sagt
ich schicke euch neue flüchtlinge rüber
wie ernst diese drohungen zu nehmen
ich finde es erst mal fair und ehrlich
bleiben die türkei hat mit über vier
millionen flüchtlingen viel mehr
flüchtlinge aufgenommen als europa in
deutschland war die hölle los
dass wir über eine million geräte haben
der türkei sind es über vier millionen
insofern war das abkommen mit der türkei
auch kein schmutziger deal sondern wir
haben auf der einen seite unsere
interessen gewahrt die flüchtlings
zuwanderung zur begrenzten andererseits
der türkei übrigens mit hilfe der
vereinten nationen geld zur versorgung
der flüchtlinge zu geben jetzt wächst
der innenpolitische druck in der türkei
die wirtschaftliche lage ist schwieriger
deswegen gibt es viel mehr konflikte
zwischen der einheimischen bevölkerung
und flüchtlingen deswegen müssen wir
auch mit dem thema druck auf die türkei
vorsichtig umgehen das gehört auch zur
wahrheit würden wir diese konflikte
verschärfen würde das erstens nicht dazu
führen dass erdogan seiner politik
ändert sondern zweitens er versucht
ventile für den inhaltlichen konflikt zu
finden
je schlechter die wirtschaftliche lage
in der türkei ist desto größer die
auseinandersetzung zwischen
einheimischer bevölkerung und den
flüchtlingen insofern wir sind in einer
ganz ganz komplizierten lage für die es
keine einfache lösung geben wird die
hoffnung kann wirklich nur bestehen dass
wir mit diplomatischen mitteln auch mit
der intervention russlands die türkei
daran hindern voranzugehen gleichzeitig
safe zu uns schaffen für flüchtlinge und
humanitäre hilfe leisten
das ist eine lage bei der es jetzt keine
einfachen möglichkeiten mehr gibt
sagt der vorsitzende des netzwerks
atlantik brücke und ehemalige
bundesaußenminister sigmar gabriel
vielen dank fürs gespräch bitte und das
gespräch aber aus termingründen ganz
kurz vor dieser sendung aufgezeichnet
jetzt nachrichten kann soll und die
beginnt mit der innenpolitik nach dem
angriff auf eine synagoge in halle
fordern die sicherheitsbehörden erneut
mehr kompetenzen
man beobachte schon länger dass rechte
gewalt und propaganda delikte zu nehmen
so bka-chef münch derzeit registriere
man 43 rechte gefährder das potenzial
der gewaltbereiten liege werk
verfassungsschutzbericht sogar bei
12.700 rechte gewalttaten und drohungen
führten zu einem klima der angst und
gefährdeten die demokratie zurück die
große koalition hat ihr klima paket in
einigen punkten nachgebessert
so soll die steuer auf flugtickets
stärker steigen als bisher geplant und
bei der fahrt zur arbeit sollen auch
geringverdiener entlastet werden die
nicht von der steigenden
pendlerpauschale profitieren
dafür ist nun eine sogenannte mobilitäts
pauschale vorgesehen
das bundeskabinett will die änderungen
morgen beschließen zusammen mit mehreren
anderen maßnahmen wie stark umweltthemen
vor allem die jüngere generation
beschäftigen das zeigt die neue shell
jugendstudie darin geben 71 prozent der
befragten an sich über die
umweltzerstörung sorgen zu machen 65
prozent haben angst vom klimawandel mit
der demokratie in deutschland sind 77
prozent der jugendlichen zufrieden doch
viele zeigen sich auch skeptisch 33
werden von den forschern als
populistisch eingestuft jeder zehnte
stimmte sogar fast allen abgefragten
parolen zu niedergebrannte hütten
mehrere verletzte auf der griechischen
insel samos sind afghanische und
syrische migranten gewaltsam aufeinander
losgegangen
dabei brach außerhalb des offiziellen
flüchtlingslagers ein feuer aus das erst
am frühen morgen unter kontrolle war
aus dem völlig überfüllten auffanglager
wurden etliche menschen in sicherheit
gebracht
ausgelegt ist es auf 650 bewohner
zurzeit leben dort aber mehr als 4000
gramm
nach der verurteilung mehrerer
separatistenführer gehen die proteste in
katalonien weiter am abend versammelten
sich tausende anhänger der
unabhängigkeitsbewegung dabei gab es
wieder zusammenstöße mit der polizei
bereits vergangene nacht waren die
proteste eskaliert
außerdem versuchten tausende
demonstranten den flughafen lahm zu
legen mehr als hundert flüge wurden
gestrichen
zurück nach deutschland es wird ein
schlagabtausch mit bergen von akten das
ist jetzt schon klar 50 dick bepackte
ordner steuert der
bundesverkehrsminister bei und will
damit belegen dass er so hätte handeln
müssen wie er gehandelt hat
die opposition glaubt ihm kein wort
andreas scheuer so sagt sie ist
verantwortlich für einen schaden von bis
zu 500 millionen euro auf dem der
steuerzahler sitzen bleibe es geht um
die pkw-maut in deutschland die kommt
zwar nicht weil der europäische
gerichtshof sie für rechtswidrig erklärt
hat aber sie hat jetzt ein nachspiel im
parlament einen untersuchungsausschuss
solches vorgehen klären und könnte den
minister in bedrängnis bringen
felix zimmermann
die macht kommt aber wenn sie nicht
kommt die wandel und die maut so wie sie
im koalitionsvertrag uns beruhigt die
maut kommt europa konform mit keiner
zusätzlichen belastung für die inländer
und mit mehr mittel für die
infrastruktur die maut kommt die fünf
jahre später steht andreas scheuer als
verkehrsminister von akten haufen
gescheitert haben auch dokumente
verspricht transparenz um einen
untersuchungsausschuss abzuwenden wir
stehen bei allen fragen zur pkw maut für
maximal mögliche transparenz
doch die opposition überzeugt er damit
nicht ja heuer redet von transparente
hatte war bisher überhaupt keine
transparenz hergestellt er hat dokumente
vorgelegt die nicht zur sachaufklärung
beitragen das verkehrsministerium räumt
etwa selbst ein dass er zu bestimmten
treffen mit den maut firmen gar keine
gesprächsvermerk gebe fdp linke grüne im
bundestag haben nun einen
untersuchungsausschuss auf den weg
gebracht der aufklärungsbedarf ist groß
etwa warum wartete der minister nicht
auf das ogh urteil zur maut bevor er
verträge mit teuren konsequenzen
unterschrieb nach warnungen des
wissenschaftlichen dienstes des
bundestages die maut sei
europarechtswidrig attestierte er dem
dienst fachliche ignoranz während sein
vorgänger alexander dobrindt 2015
äußerte wir verhalten uns
rechtsstaatlich und werden eine
gerichtsentscheidung abwarten konnte es
für scheuer nicht schnell genug gehen
das schaue er nicht auf das ogh-urteil
wartete ist vor allem deswegen brisant
weil der vertrag für die mautbetreiber
eine teure entschädigung vorsieht die
erstattung des sogenannten brutto
unternehmenswerts der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler professor
hoffmann erklärt die regelung also sie
zahlen für einen vertragszeitraum von
zwölf jahren die komplette rendite
obwohl das unternehmen nur sechs monate
für sie arbeitet stellen sich das vor
als arbeitnehmer sie arbeiten sechs
monate für ein unternehmen und bekommen
dann quasi als abfindung das gehalt von
12 jahren unvorstellbar im
verkehrsausschuss rechtfertigt der
andreas scheuer die klausel als
angemessene übliche regelung auf
nachfrage des zdf in welchen anderen
verträgen die angeblich so übliche
regelungen sonst noch auftaucht
antwortete das ministerium nicht
aufklären will der
untersuchungsausschuss auf die frage ob
bei der vergabe der maut verträge
getrickst wurde die pkw maut war im
herbst letzten jahres tot weil der
rahmen des haushalts gesetzgebers von
zwei milliarden nicht ausreicht es gab
nur ein angebot über drei milliarden die
kosten wurden in die zukunft und auf
andere geschoben nur deswegen war es
möglich den kostenrahmen von drei auf
zwei milliarden zu senken
rechtswissenschaftler sie ihn in
versteckten kosten ein problem der
haushaltsgesetzgeber soll nach dem
grundsatz der haushaltswahrheit und
haushaltsklarheit genau wissen worauf
sich der staat ein lässt und wie hoch
die kosten werden und dem steht so ein
verstecken in laufenden kosten natürlich
deutlich entgegen
andreas scheuer sieht keinen anlass für
einen untersuchungsausschuss
ich habe den antragsentwurf zum
untersuchungsausschuss gesehen ich habe
alle punkte durchgegangen und bin
draufgekommen dass wir eigentlich zu
allen gegenständen schon auskunft
gegeben haben aber dann geben wir heute
wieder auskunft
nächste woche wird der bundestag noch
förmlich über die einsetzung des
untersuchungsausschusses abstimmen
die chronologie zum problem projekt pkw
maut zum nachlesen auf heute die jetzt
noch mal nachrichten noch mal kasse
stromkunden müssen sich auf höhere
preise einstellen
denn die ökostrom umlage steigt im
kommenden jahr um fünfeinhalb prozent
auf knapp 6,8 cent pro kilowattstunde
das bedeutet für einen
durchschnittshaushalt rund 18 euro mehr
im jahr
mit der sogenannten eeg-umlage wird der
ausbau der erneuerbaren energien
finanziert sie macht rund ein viertel
des strompreises aus der handelskonflikt
zwischen den usa und china drückt
zunehmend auf die weltwirtschaft deshalb
hat der internationale währungsfonds
seine konjunktur prognose leicht gesenkt
und das bekommt in deutschland vor allem
der mittelstand zu spüren
das wurde heute gleich durch mehrere
ereignisse deutlich von bethmann in
frankfurt wie ist dann die aktuelle lage
beim deutschen mittelstand besonders der
teil der stark vom export abhängig ist
wie die vielen zulieferer in der
automobilindustrie
sie bekommen die krise immer schärfer zu
spüren auch die erfolgsverwöhnten
deutschen maschinenbauer spüren die
verunsichert
und ihre kunden infolge der handel
streitigkeiten die aufträge gehen zurück
die produktion der branche liegt derzeit
1,6 prozent unter dem vorjahreswert ließ
der dachverband heute verkünden und die
bundeskanzlerin bezeichnete die
konjunkturelle entwicklung in
deutschland insgesamt als
besorgniserregend molltöne auch vom
internationalen währungsfond heute die
weltkonjunktur bremst sich ein
überdurchschnittlich in deutschland das
von den zoll streitigkeiten besonders
betroffen ist der iwf hat seine prognose
die welt werde 2009 10 nur noch um 3,0
prozent wachsen was sich noch nach einem
ordentlichen wachstum anhört ist
faktisch der schlechteste wert seit der
weltwirtschaftskrise vor zehn jahren
auch die börsianer blicken aktuell mehr
als skeptisch nach vorn rechnen mit
einer weiteren verschlechterung der
konjunktur in deutschland die
pessimistische stimmung auf dem
maschinenbau gipfel gilt als warnung ist
die branche doch so etwas wie ein
frühindikator
die deutschen fischer dürfen im
kommenden jahr deutlich weniger tiere
fangen als bisher in der westlichen
ostsee senken die zuständigen minister
der eu länder die quoten für hering um
65 und für dorsch um 60 prozent
außerdem bereiteten sie die schonzeiten
für den dorsch aus ursprünglich sollten
die fangquoten noch stärker sinken doch
deutschland stellte sich dagegen um die
existenz der fischer zu sichern
umweltschützern gehen die einschnitte
nicht weit genug
bei der qualifikation für die fußball em
ist der sport gestern abend in den
hintergrund geraten denn die partie
bulgarien gegen england stand zweimal
kurz vor dem abbruch wegen rassistischer
entgleisungen bulgarischer zuschauer und
beim spiel frankreich gegen die türkei
hatten türkische spieler ein tor mit
einem militärischen gruß bejubelt
offenbar in bezug auf die umstrittene
militäroffensive in nordsyrien die uefa
hat gegen die betroffenen verbände
untersuchungen
geleitet 285.000 besucher darunter ein
königspaar so ist das wenn in frankfurt
buchmesse ist und norwegen der ehrengast
die buchmesse ist die größte weltweit
wurde norwegen sprechen sie gerade von
einem goldenen zeitalter ihrer literatur
passt also der fokus auf die
gesellschaft ist ein markenzeichen von
büchern aus norwegen egal ob beim
nordischen krimi oder bei denen gerade
in den letzten jahren beliebten werken
mit autobiografischen zügen gerade mal
etwas mehr als fünf millionen einwohner
und ein literarisches wunderland
norwegen kauft von jedem buch generell
immer schon mal fast 1000 exemplare vor
ab und gibt sie an die bibliotheken
weiter und bringt seine buch szene jetzt
auch zu uns runter nach deutschland wie
stephan merseburger zeigt da rollt
royaler glanz auf dem frankfurter
hauptbahnhof ein ökologisch korrekt
kommt das kronprinzenpaar aus norwegen
mit der bahn
sie bringen zur eröffnung der buchmesse
rund 100 autoren mit der literatur zug
ist mette-marit eine herzenssache in
norwegen reist sie jeden sommer mit
autoren durchs land um junge und alte
leser zu treffen
jetzt ein sonderzug von berlin nach
frankfurt schmücker stunde mit berliner
schülern gerade die jungen und ihre
fragen müsse man ernst nehmen so mette
marit
sie selbst ist mit büchern aufgewachsen
und hält literatur für lebenswichtig
literatur schafft viel verständnis für
die anderen
darin liegt ihre ganze schönheit wir
können uns selbst und die anderen besser
verstehen und sie gibt uns etwas
gemeinsames etwas das vereint das ist
wichtig
die landschaft ist weit und wunderbar
norwegen hat etwas mehr als fünf
millionen einwohner oder erlebt gerade
eine literarische blütezeit
josten garde hat mit sophies welt den
menschen die philosophie erklärt und
landete einen welterfolg sein neues buch
genau richtig handelt von alter
krankheit und vom verlust der würde im
sterben
seit jahren besorgt garda der
klimawandel
gerne redet er der nation ins gewissen
wir tragen verantwortung wir als
reichstes land der welt sollten sofort
aufhören weiter nach öl in der nordsee
zu buchen
es ist ein fakt das klima verträgt es
nicht wenn wir all das carbon rausholen
und einfach verbrennen wir müssen damit
aufhören nach öl und gas verdankt das
einst bitterarme norwegen seinen
reichtum und die reserven sind noch
längst nicht erschöpft
maja runde hat sich mit ihrem bestseller
die geschichte der bienen in die herzen
der deutschen leser geschrieben
ihr neuer roman die letzten ihrer art
handelt auch von der erderwärmung ein
handlungsstrang spielt im jahr 2064 der
klimakollaps ist eingetreten
der alltag im frühjahr komfortablen
norwegen ist zum kampf ums überleben
geworden nahrung fehlt wir sind sehr
besorgt über unsere zukunft und den
klimawandel
wir fürchten das zu verlieren was wir so
sehr lieben die natur ist ein großer
teil unserer sehen die meisten norweger
sind ihr sehr verbunden
schriftsteller die etwas zu sagen haben
geschichten die aktuell und politisch
sind norwegen ist ein aufregendes
gastland
und warum lesen so viele deutsche
besonders gern krimis aus norwegen wurde
die organisatorin des norwegischen
auftritt auf der buchmesse gefragt ihre
antwort weil unsere krimis ziemlich gut
sind ziemlich gut ist auch jede woche
dienstags die sendung nach uns 37 grad
feiert jubiläum und folgt heute
jugendlichen die fürs klima kämpfen mal
laut mal leise
es lohnt sich rein zu schauen was da auf
uns zukommt und morgen kommt das
heute-journal wieder auf sie zu und wäre
es natürlich sind dabei für heute vielen
dank des zuschauers
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren teams
sind so spannend weil sie so
unterschiedlich sein können zum beispiel
so ein kleines tief dass hier
eingeklemmt am west alpenbogen sehr viel
regen zum beispiel nach genua bringt das
tief sebastian ist deutlich dynamischer
unterwegs brachte uns heute regen und
morgen kommt dann schon dieses
regengebiet von tief kilo bei uns an
jetzt in der nacht ist es also häufig
stark bewölkt es gibt kräftigen regen
sind auch gewitter dabei
und die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 13 grad in nordfriesland und 5
grad am alpenrand morgen über tag wird
sie in norddeutschland zumindest mein
schleswig holstein und in
mecklenburg-vorpommern kaum wärmer als
es in der nacht war mit 14 grad sonst
liegen die temperaturen in
norddeutschland bei 13 bis 17 grad
das liegt daran dass es morgen noch
kräftig weiter regnet ihre posten erst
am nachmittag zieht der regen nach osten
ab dann gibt es einen freundlichen
streifen hier von den ostfriesischen
inseln bis zum harz dazu pfeift der wind
böig aus südwest und von westen kommt
schon wieder die nächsten regenwolken
von tief tiere heran
die treffen zum beispiel auch das
saarland und rheinland pfalz südlich der
donau aber wird es morgen sehr
freundlich zum teil am alpenrand sogar
sonnig und die temperaturen in
süddeutschland sind auch höher
sie steigen zum teil wie hier in
freiburg im breisgau bis 20 grad in den
nächsten tagen geht es zwar wechselhaft
weiter
aber es bleibt doch im wesentlichen mit
schönen abend noch